hey welcome back I'm Jesse and for those
that don't know him here at the Wolfram
technology conference 2017 talking to
developers and other interesting people
who are using our technology and some
really cool ways I'm here with Patrick
who's so part of our math course he's
just a muddler
he's gonna tell us a little bit more
about what exactly that is and what he's
doing here at the conference right so
what we have a Jesse is a virtual model
that were built of a robotic arm so
before we went ahead and we actually
built a real the real thing but before
we went ahead and built that we could
try different scenarios on a virtual
prototype and this is really good in for
example an industrial environment if
you're building like this these really
expensive things if you're building a
really expensive six degree robotic off
you want to be absolutely sure that what
you're building will perform the way you
wanted to perform in the design stage
it's one of those things that system
augment can be used for system although
it's also very useful in for example
education if you in this case if you
were having a mechatronics class you
want to understand control systems you
want to understand advanced topics like
inverse kinematics then you can also use
system moment for that but it's most of
our customers are within product
development I think so that so the thing
we could see for example was if the
robot the robot design if it were able
to reach the places we wanted it to
reach you can go ahead and move some of
these sliders
oh and you'll see that the virtual model
of the robotic arm performs just in the
same way as the real stuff does yeah and
you can see we have some like googly
eyes yeah there was a last-minute design
change that we really should have
incorporated became it looks absolutely
cute now yeah so you notice it you'll
notice a if I turn this around a bit and
sorry and you can do that same thing you
did with the kind of square that you
were mapping out you'll notice that it's
it's keeping it in a certain plane and
that's due to one of the control systems
that are running behind this so what we
could do then is without actually trying
it on the actual hardware we could try a
control system that keeps it in level
like this on the virtual thingy that
that saves a lot of production costs
it's a it's easier to iterate over many
different designs without actually
endangering the real hardware so the
trick here is that with those two
sliders you move it in the if we call
this they back and forth over the X
direction and in the Y direction up and
down then you need to move there are
three servos here that you need to move
in unison in order to actually keep it
in that
in that place and that is what the
control system does that we could map
out on the model-based design rather
than on the real one and then of course
it only has a limited reach so a good
for example say that or what if we
increased the length of the arm would
that reach the places we wanted it to
reach and you can move this one all
sites oh it's back and forth it's this
one right well it moves it back and
forth but then but then it has a bit
limited reach which means that it will
kind of adjust the other ones but
so how exactly is this working like it
see here you have like a you have a
breadboard and yeah we know so let me
show you a bit what's happening behind
the scenes and I'll open up system over
here and this is where we built this
real-time control so what we have here
the start of all of it is a
representation of this Arduino ball here
and it gets three inputs that it sends
three control actually let me go into
this one and you'll see that it just
consists of a model of this order II
know that establishes a real-time
connection you can just build this using
dragon off your dragon drag this board
into the diagram here and then we have
some different things representing the
different pins on the board and then you
adjust this you could run it in real
time and you'll get back the data from
the arena and then we do some limiting
of the signal and then we send it back
into that controller that I talked about
the beeps it in that plane so that is
what we call inverse kinematics and from
though so input the angles we wanted to
vote the coordinates we wanted to be and
we wanted to be in a certain X Y and set
a position and what we got back from
that is a are three angles three angles
for these three servers and then we send
those three angles to for example we
said we can send it to this model here
and it will tell the service in the
model what they should do and we can see
how it how they move and we can also
send it to a new Arduino board and
that's the one back here my dear it's
hard to see that this one takes the
real-time signals send it to this
breadboard which powers the servos and
gives it the signal where it should move
so that's why it's happening both in a
virtual environment and in the real
thing so are there I'm guessing they're
easy ways to sort of change the
direction of the motion you know so this
isn't so like XY
yes you could one thing you could do for
example is you could allow this these to
set the angles on the service so instead
of saying setting the positions then you
can say okay aunt and that would be much
easier then we wouldn't have need to
have this block we'll just connect it up
like this and then that would indicate
how it should move of course you could
swap it around or you could you know
implement any other type of controller
system that you want you could say that
this should be the velocity that it
moves that instead but that would be a
lot harder to control right yeah there's
a lot of flexibility that comes with
being able to having to and you know if
if these were to set the velocity of
their servos then you can you could end
up in real bad place you know it would
easily hit if the ground that his itself
it has hit itself on a number of
occasions but we could see that in the
the model of the system we could I mean
the model behaves just assisted em could
we could also take those measurements
the essentials sensor measurements from
the robot insert them into duvall from
language and detect okay
the robot get itself again that was bad
what can we eat to rate to to do that
and we could do that very rapidly
because we're not doing it on the real
thing we do get in the computer so
wolfram system onler has been out for a
little while but i know that there was
now unlike latest version that was a
release version 5 what are some of the
like latest features that you know
implemented in that version versus
yeah so one thing that is a system only
is a library where you that you can use
with pre-built components that you just
drag-and-drop and community together to
build different types of systems for
example there's a library for building
electronic circuits or there's a library
for building mechanical systems so in
system on the 500 that that library got
updated with some new things like power
converters it has fluid and gas media
that you can model so there's a lot of
new things there also we made we always
try to make the integration with the
vault from language smoother and tighter
and one of the things you can do now is
you can think of this model as a yes as
any other Wolfram language function
the thing you call that function with
different parameter values so it could
be the length of the robot arm there
could be a parameter value and that's an
input T to the function which is this
model okay and then you could just call
that function with a new value for the
the arm and then you can do an analysis
on that see okay where how long did the
robot reach with these parameter values
yeah so these are now like symbolic
elements that can be manipulated just
like anything else
yeah and that's something that we are
continuing to iterate on and there will
be some really exciting changes there
coming in just a little while where my
model will truly be a symbolical
representation in the whole front
language that'd be cool um thanks again
Patrick we're taking the time to set all
this if you all have any questions I
like usual so you leave them in the
comments we can't really get to them
doing these live sessions but someone
will be able to get back to you there's
also a prenatal from comm where there's
a system model or group so if you're
interested in seeing some of the
kind of ongoing discussions and maybe
someone has posed a question already
there so I would I would check that out
yeah thanks again Patrick thank you